I try to work with clients who work hard
like I found that if the client doesn't
want to do their own marketing like
theirs if they're just hired me to do it
for them that's not someone I want to
work with what i like about the authors
that i've i've been you know privilege
to work with and brands and stuff is
they're all interesting people who like
wanna they want to interact with the
public they want to do exciting things
and they sort of get excited about these
like stuns and opportunities and like
they want to make videos that people see
and they wanted to post it make people
talk and they're not afraid to piss
people off or make them laugh or
whatever which is totally different than
I think the old model of PR which is
like we've got a copy of your book we
made a press release than we like mailed
it out to a lot of people so I work with
great people and then like great
employees but then I also work with
great clients who understand that like
I'm helping them rather than doing it
for them i think like--look if you want
a traditional publicist like go with a
firm if you want to do cool things that
sort of leverage the internet and
leverage social media and all these all
these tools that we have to like get a
message out like that then maybe I'm
someone you want to talk to so company
like american apparel i think the reason
they've been as successful as they have
been and done all the cool things is a
they've done is that they built all that
stuff in-house so i think it's a huge
mistake that people go like okay the
most important relationship that we have
is with our customers right and the
first thing we're going to do is hire
someone else who doesn't work for us to
manage that relationship to me that's
like crazy right but i also know that
like sometimes there's outside people
who have relationships that you want
like with the media are with bloggers or
with reporters and like so when i did my
own book like I did all my own marketing
but then I also hired a firm to help me
so I think if you're if you've got good
ideas and you're looking for someone to
take you to the next level then it works
if you're again if you're looking for
someone to do it for you I think you're
going to be really disappointed with the
results bloggers know this bloggers and
youtubers they get pitches every day
from PR agencies and they go to straight
in the trash
and they don't work with those people
but you know if there's a there's a
handful of like connectors out there who
have good relationships who are always
coming to them with cool ideas if
whether it's paid or unpaid or its
promotional or not they're interested in
talking to those people and you and I
probably know a bunch of those people
and i hope to consider myself one of
them but that's the kind of thing i
think that works in this day and age
though the old model of you know like
we're 80 year old PR firm i think they
have a bunch of relationships with
people who are not nearly as influential
as they once were I mean when was the
last time when you bought something
because like you read a review about it
in the New York Times like it doesn't
happen but like you do check out things
all the time because if your friends are
chattering about them on the internet
and like I think what I've gotten good
at and a handful of other people have
gotten really good at is generating that
kind of chatter and conversation whether
it's like a viral video or a fake
controversy or a stunt or you know some
sort of marketing initiative it's like
unless it's blowing up your Facebook
feed or your Twitter feed or your
friends are emailing it to you or you
reading it on five different blogs that
you check every day that's the only way
it's going to provoke you to like do
something or act yeah so i was in
college i was i was writing for this
college newspaper i went to school in
California and they were like hey like
we want you to review a website like
will you review a website every week and
I was like yeah sure so I decided I
would review tucker max calm who was a
blogger than he was doing stories about
like getting drunk and hooking up and I
was like man I know I'm just supposed to
do a review but what if I like wrote a
really good review and then I contacted
him after and at the time he wasn't
famous he just had like a you know
popular website and we ended up sort of
creating this relationship where he
would he would give me advice on stuff I
would help him out with projects and
that turned into my first marketing kick
he was doing a book based on his website
and he's like an assistant to help and I
was like look I will work for you for
free I will do whatever you say I want I
believe in this book and I want to blow
it up and that book went on to be a
number one New York Times bestseller it
sold millions of copies he did a movie
he didn't other books and so that was my
first parade
marketing and I learned how marketing
for like online people really works so
instead of the traditional way I learned
like look this is how bloggers get
attention and this is how you get
attention from blogs and then I've I've
been able to use those lessons for all
the other clients that I've worked with
and it turns out today that's the only
way to get attention and so it
definitely set me up for what I have now
that was the base that launched me to
work for all the other authors I've
worked for talk about my job at american
apparel and that's how I that's how I
learned to write my own book too if
you're genuinely passionate about some
space chances are you have a bunch of
knowledge that Outsiders don't have that
you can leverage in exchange for them
giving you experience and things that
you don't know about like I didn't know
how book publicity worked but I knew how
blogs worked and Robert sort of showed
Robert and Tucker showed me those and I
shanna I gave them access to like I was
like hey like I think this blogger is
super influential I think this is a web
show you should be on and like I got
them hooked up on all this stuff and
like we we helped each other and I think
young people don't understand that they
have that knowledge and it's worth
something they think they look they have
to go to school and learn from a
professor how marketing works and they
have to get an internship and then then
they get a low level job and they work
their way up I think it's like look find
something new and emerging and that you
genuinely care about that's what you
should do the book is basically I tried
to rip back the curtain and show how
like the media stuff works and how what
blogs think about what they care about
how they decide what they're going to
write about and it turns out at the root
of it they care about pageviews does
this article get them traffic they kind
of care they care less whether it's true
or good and more whether it will make
people click and share it and stuff and
so I found that that like like we see
this like you see a video like the the
ego picking up the baby right like
whether that's true or not was sort of
secondary to whether it would make
people click right and then afterwards
they were kind of like oops I guess we
got fooled they don't they don't care
whereas like let's say you're a site
that has paid subscriber
is you're not going to want it you don't
you can't afford to give your your
viewers or your readers or subscribers
posts that aren't true because they'll
be like why am I paying you for this
right so I think when there's this paid
relationship or some sort of
subscription relationship like for
instance like I think a blog like The
Huffington Post probably cares less
about what its viewers think then like a
youtube channel with like 500,000
subscribers because that subscriber
count is like important to them and they
care about those people and they need to
deliver a quality product to them so
hopefully what I'm predicting or you
know advocating is a model where instead
of trying to make everything go viral
we're delivering a product to fans that
care about us and then watch it's like
if you have the same 10,000 fans who
watch every single one of your videos
you're going to deliver a higher quality
product than if you're trying to get
10,000 new people every time you're
definitely playing with fire when you
decide to start a controversy but I
think in in his case and with a lot of
the clients that I work with what
they're what I respect about them is
that they don't give a [ __ ] about people
who aren't their fans so it's like do
his fans think this is funny do they
like it are they going to talk about it
if the answer is yes then it doesn't
matter about pissing off these other
people who weren't going to buy from you
anyway like polarization i think is very
underrated like people think like oh
I've got to please everyone all the time
but videos that please everyone are not
the kind that spread like there's this
fascinating study of articles in the New
York Times like the articles that made
the most read section in the New York
Times turns out the number one predictor
of virality and an article is how angry
it makes the reader the reason is like
when you're angry when you read an
article that makes you angry you're like
oh my god I have to show this to
everyone if you read an article that's
like oh yeah it was a good article
you're not like cher cher like everyone
has to see this right so it's it's about
the reaction that the content provokes
and it just happens that controversy or
pissing people off is a very
provocative emotion that a hand for my
clients have used I mean how many ads do
we see that immediately leave our heads
that we never think about again and
someone paid a lot of money for us to
see that newspaper ads billboards
television it's like we view it and we
instantly forget it but Pete adds like I
could probably name like five of them
off the top of my head and what's ironic
is they spend a fraction of what Pepsi
or coke or whatever spends and so I
definitely think like look if you're
young and scrappy and trying to spread a
message and you don't have the kind of
budgets that a billion-dollar brand
would you you've got it you've got to
take certain risks and you've got it yes
stir stuff up like what's the worst that
can happen if someone says like check
out this article I hate it so much they
forget that they're still saying like
check out this article and they're
sharing it to people and people are
still clicking it and like I think as
long as the content is good at the end
of the day like it's like for instance
uh you know when people used to do
thumbnail cheating on youtube if the
video sucked it didn't really matter you
know but if you click it because you
think there's going to be a girl in a
bikini in it and then it turns out to be
funny that's that's what you want right
and and I think you can bait in similar
ways with media narratives you don't
want to there are certain things that
you don't want to be accused of or
talked about of right like if you're a
yoga studio maybe you don't want to be
controversial I get it but the reality
is i think obscurity like no one knowing
who you are and nobody ever talking
about you is a worse problem than
everyone talking about you all the time
for a variety of reasons basically I
when I was really studying with the
history of media and i was looking at
like how publicity was done like in the
early 1900's like in the yellow
journalism period I saw like people
people were just like way more creative
and they had more fun like they were
there were always these fascinating
hoaxes and like controversies and wars
between newspapers they're always trying
to one-up each other and like that was
how you got attention back then was like
you do these interesting things
like you would create a fake riot and
then the newspapers would write about it
or whatever you know like mysterious
object washes up on the shore and then
there's all this speculation about it
and I think that that that environment
is very similar to our media environment
today like all these people that all
trying to like get us to click and read
and I think that's that similar that's a
similar environment and so I tried to
adjust some of my marketing tactics
using inspiration from stuff that was
like 100 150 years ago people be like oh
you were able to do that with American
Apparel that's because they're like a
household name but like you know when I
met Tucker he'd sold zero books and when
I meant Tim Ferriss revered for his
first book hadn't come out so it's
clearly possible that you can go from
you know being unknown to being a
household name bye-bye sort of
leveraging the internet and social media
and blogs to to get publicity and what
happens is like where do you think
reporters and mainstream media
influencers like radio producers or
television producers or host or whatever
what do you think they'd find out about
what school and new right they go on the
internet like the rest of us so what I
found is like if you can generate blog
attention you get the right people in
social media to be talking about you the
next thing you know a producer from CNN
is calling and saying hey we want to
have you on the show or radio host in
Kansas City is like how I saw your post
i loved it will you come talk about it
and you get that's how you get the
attention is it what starts online ends
offline and I mean how many of these
memes started on tiny forums and the
next thing you know they're on like good
morning america so it's totally possible
and i think it's much more likely that
someone will create something new from
scratch on the internet we've never
heard of tomorrow then it will be that
like Pepsi comes up with a cool new meme
like that's just not going to happen
because small independent youtubers and
bloggers and Twitter folk or whatever
they're going to be they're going to be
willing to take the risk they can
experiment they can just I mean
something like Harlem shake that's just
a guy he throws up some video and
because it started getting traction he
was able to make it
and bigger and bigger but I don't think
you know company with 10,000 employees
is going to take a risk on some tiny
little YouTube video and then see what
happens they just don't it's not in
their DNA but for the smaller people
they can they can afford to do that and
it's friends with their only option I
mean what's the downside your video does
0 views the upside is that it does 100
million views like that's really cool
and whereas if you're in a big company
or you work at a social media agency or
an ad agency someone's paying you tens
of thousands of dollars a month to make
this stuff if your video does 0 views
you get fired so they're they're always
true it's like second Hollywood why they
keep churning out these crappy romantic
comedies instead of taking real artistic
risks because it's like they know
romantic comedy will make X amount at
the box office they can't afford for it
to make zero dollars and that's what
happens when you experiment is sometimes
you're wrong and I would definitely say
enjoy the ability to be wrong because
that's where the cool stuff comes from
people make these products that aren't
interesting and then they're like oh how
do we get facebook fans or how do we get
Twitter followers and it's like why do
you want them like you're not that you
can't put them to use because your thing
isn't worth talking about you know like
there was that thing where coke was
saying like social media does it drive
sales for them it's like how would
social media drive sales of a soda
that's been around for a hundred years
you can't like construct a crazy cool
video like from from math it's got to
come from some sort of like creative
inspiration or cool idea those things
help you take it to the next level but
like there has to be that spark with the
idea and I think what my clients are
good at is making that product or idea
or stunned that really gets people
excited and then the stuff like
pay-per-click ads and social media and
analytics all that comes into play in
terms of like spreading it and making it
big but the end of the day it's like the
internet needs interesting things that
make people want to share them and if
your product doesn't do that it's kind
of dead in the water a lot of the
clients I work with two books I really
like books I think people need to read
more and so I would definitely
take a look at that space because you
know making short youtube videos that
make people laugh are great but can you
spend a year of your life like working
on a book that people will read and will
change their life I think that's really
important to